des civilisations Emmanuel Macron a
repris hier ce néologisme pour décrire
la France de 2023 des civilisations ce
n'est pas nouveau c'est un processus qui
a commencé il y a de nombreuses années
c'est aussi un mot de Renaud Camus
écrivain classé à droite un concept
qu'il développa dans un ouvrage en 2011
et comme toujours quand une analyse du
réel ne convient pas à la bien-pensance
et les qualifier d'idées d'extrême
droite vous savez que moi le père la
mère du meilleur ami Gaspard de mon aîné
et les Américaines et quand elles vont
réunion parents-prof elle me dit mais en
me donne que le négatif
est en marche 40 ans d'autorité bafouée
40 ans d'école sacrifiée 40 ans de
Petits Hommes Gris 40 ans de hiérarchie
oubliée 40 ans de valeur travail
déprécier 40 ans de christianisme effacé
40 ans d'immigration incontrôlée 40 ans
de déni orchestré 40 ans de laisser
aller de l'acheter de compromission 40
ans qui ont déclassé la France Emmanuel
Macron s'est réveillé hier mieux vaut
tard que jamais mais convenons qu'il
était temps depuis le début de la
semaine
cette carapace ça se trouve c'est
peut-être un nounours sous carton mais
j'ai quand même des doutes
et si vous l'aviez laissé vivre
c'est le message anti-avortement que de
nombreux Parisiens ont pu découvrir ce
matin avant de prendre un Vélib'
cette campagne sauvage s'est déroulée
pendant la nuit plusieurs centaines de
vélos ont été étiquetés la réaction des
internautes ne s'est pas fait attendre
beaucoup considèrent ces messages comme
objectif et rappelle leurs droits les
responsables de cette action sont un
collectif anti-IVG appelé les survivants
[Musique]
un kiwi a failli être la cause d'un
incident diplomatique entre la
Nouvelle-Zélande et les États-Unis on ne
parle pas du fruit mais de l'oiseau
emblème du pays des All Blacks qui
aurait été maltraité dans un zoo de
Floride
l'établissement proposait aux visiteurs
de caresser et nourrir le volatile pour
une vingtaine d'euros problème c'est un
animal nocturne et très peu sociable si
le zoo de Miami s'est excusé pour
l'incident
de nombreux internautes réclament le
retour du kiwi sur sa terre natale
[Musique]
on fait leur rentrée guerre au musée
Grévin à Paris alors regardez enfin je
pense que vous allez reconnaître il
s'agit d'Antoine Dupont Antoine du 15 de
France est meilleur joueur du monde et
Frédéric Michalak les gens du Stade
Toulousain meilleur buteur de l'histoire
des Bleus inauguration en leur présence
et au lieu hier soir alors qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que c'est assez
réussi pour vous parce que ça dépend des
statuts
vaut bien autant d'excitation chez ses
photographes impossible pour eux de
rater ses quelques pas de Garcia un
paraplégique qui parvient à remarcher le
fruit de plus de 10 années de recherches
en France et en Suisse pour ça des
implants ont été placés dans le cerveau
et la moelle épinière de ce néerlandais
de 40 ans une opération qui permet de
rétablir ses connexions nerveuses et le
rendre davantage maître de ses
mouvements
extrêmement concentré
[Applaudissements]
enfin la star du jour c'est Savannah un
chihuahua qui poste des selfies d'elle
avec des stars sur son compte Instagram
alors il y a Adèle Exarchopoulos
Benjamin Biolay Virginie Efira et
beaucoup plus étonnant
Johnny Depp
[Applaudissements]
la brève de la semaine à mon sens il
violait des chevaux et des coller à
Saint-Nazaire mon client n'est pas
dégénéré finalement ça pose pas mal de
questions s'il est pas dégénéré ce qu'on
peut quand même pas dire qu'il est pas
très à cheval sur le consentement l'air
de rien celle qui se cache derrière
Savannah a trouvé là un super moyen
d'approcher les stars alors en général
j'ai justement des photos et des
réactions qui changent de l'ordinaire
certains me disaient mais il faut
recommencer parce que vous êtes pas sur
la photo je dis non non c'est fait pour
il y avait une décision le réalisateur
voulait mettre un plan de sexe dans le
film à un moment donné pour montrer
l'humiliation masculine il voulait
filmer le sexe du personnage en gros
plan qui débande et c'est là où ça va
poser un vrai problème je suis allé le
voir et je vous dis
moi je peux pas faire ça quoi l'histoire
de heavy metal est aussi abrasif que ces
rives de guitare du procès du groupe du
DA Street accusé d'avoir poussé au
soucis vos adolescents on me plaint de
bruit et de fureur sensible
à télécharger sur l'appli Radio France
et France inter.fr
il me dit on va prendre une doublure
de mal avec ça et puis je savais qu'il
allait pas le faire qu'il allait pas le
monter ça n'a été coupé effectivement
selon
la moitié regardez 38 % des Français
interrogés disent avoir trompé entre
l'âge de 18 et 34 ans 51% entre 35 et 49
ans 66% 66%. après
écoutez ça fait beaucoup de monde de
mal parce que nous on est dans les 66
avec les amis
alors votre cœur s'est fendu
[Rires]